[Music]
we're going to go to new orleans with
tina hey tina how are you
i'm fine thank you how are you today
great what's going on
well
i am 55 and i'm disabled so i can't use
this money that i came into for
investments and things because then
this takes away my disability
so i'm wondering i have a older car
not you know has over 100 000 miles if i
should take this money
and pay cash
for i'm thinking like a kia or something
that will last me a good 15 or 20 years
what kind of car do you have now
right now i have a 2010 dodge caliber
um that is a salvaged vehicle and has
over 102 000 miles on it
okay
so what's the what's wrong with this car
now
there's not a lot wrong with it but like
i said because i'm on disability i can't
just hold on to this cash i mean i guess
i could hide it under my mattress and
nobody would know
but um i'm thinking you know maybe a new
car
and i'm thinking brand new with no miles
on it that would last me
until hopefully i almost died or can't
drive anymore
i just i i
i i don't know the details of the the
limitations on disability income so you
may have to help me and george you jump
in here you're the finance expert in
this scenario but i i am i do feel like
you've got to have more options than
just putting all this money into a brand
new car or under your mattress i feel
like i must be missing something here
there must be another option i'm not not
considering no i'm only allowed to have
two thousand dollars in my bank account
what money are we referring to what
money did you get and where did it come
from
um i had a small piece of property in
mexico and i sold it okay
can you reinvest that money into real
estate or into anything else that does
not go down in value like a car
i live with my mom so i don't need to
invest in real estate or a house because
i'll be getting her house when she
passes away
um
and if i don't have a house that i'm
personally living in
then
um according to their rules i can't do
that
interesting
social
security and you're saying you can't
invest it okay
um no they say i can't invest it because
then it's considered income and then
they'll take away from a little bit i
get every month i get like 720 a month
well this is so stupid
yeah
are we trying to not take care of people
that are struggling with disability i
mean this is so dumb i've i've never
heard the finer details of this i feel
like this is a future
podcast yeah this might be a future
episode tina you got us on this one so
let's talk about this
um do you have any debt
um no i have no debt
my only bill that i have right now is my
25 a month gym membership and my
insurance on this car
okay well that's good news let's talk
about this car now you said i need a new
car i want to drive this thing for 15 to
20 years and we don't recommend that
people buy new cars unless they are
millionaires because it goes down like a
rock in value and let me tell you the
mileage part i drive an 09 honda civic
that has 160 000 miles on it i'm
probably the seventh owner i have no
idea how many owners came before me and
she pursed christy she drives great and
so i the idea that you need to get a new
car because of reliability or the
mileage i think you can get a great used
car maybe for how much cash do you have
to spend on this car if you didn't take
out any debt um
if i don't take out any debt i have
about 26 000 oh my goodness okay you're
going to be living large in this car
this is fantastic news so i would i
personally
in your position probably wouldn't spend
26 000 on a used car um but you can get
a great reliable car um obviously toyota
and honda are known for if you're
looking for longevity uh there's they're
they're going out there they're 300 plus
thousand miles on toyotas and honda's
out there uh with very little
maintenance and i don't know about you
i'm not a fixer-upper i'm no chip gaines
i'm no bear grylls i'm not a diy guy
tina so
this shocks me jordan
the shocker too many many of americans
listening today so if i'm you i'm i'm
going to get a used uh toyota or a used
honda if you're looking for longevity
and mileage and you can do that for well
under 20 grand
all right the one that is yeah go ahead
sorry no go ahead tina
what do you think about ikea
i hear good things about that i okay
here's my personal take and uh kia's
come a long way i will say that but as a
person who has researched a lot of cars
i have found that kias are not going to
be uh in the top you know the top five
uh when it comes to longevity
maintenance cost all those types of
things so
i would look into a toyota honda accord
or civic on the honda side uh camry or
avalon on the toyota side if you're if
you like a sedan and that's going to get
you very far for a long long period of
time with very little uh time in the
shop yeah i don't know about you but
bringing my car to the shop is a
nightmare so that's that's my personal
take i'm sure there's review sites out
there that'll put key in the top and
some of their vehicles um may be better
but if i just want to not worry about it
i'm probably going to yoda honda from in
your shoes yeah just for the the
reliability and this is multiple
different uh objective sites that that
rate these cards this is not just george
and his opinion even though we we do all
have the brands that we like or we go to
first um but look into it the other
thing i'll say tina and i and i'm guilty
of being just you know i get on
i'm really persistent with things but i
just i really want you to sit down with
someone um
a financial coach we you know we've got
these here at ramsey solutions uh an
investment professional someone to dig
into this is there any other
way around it not because you can't get
a car that's not the point of this
i just hate the fact that you're making
a decision on a car
mainly because you're not allowed to
keep this money that is your money
when there may be a way to spend 10 of
it on a used car and then do something
with the other 16 or maybe in the future
if you it are some inherit some money or
something to to know what your options
are versus oh i've just got to get rid
of it because i'm not allowed to have it
that is just that is i don't like her
being locked in like that i don't like
any of it to be mad will you just will
you just keep looking tina will you keep
looking into that sit down with an
investment professional or a financial
coach and just see
if you have any other options you may
not be aware of that are not as
widely known at this point i want what's
best for you and so does george